it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive low prices and in this
Good Housekeeping Edition we're showing
you some products tested by Good
Housekeeping to start shopping now scan
the QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com Jessica Tice is the Deputy
editor of Good Housekeeping Institute
and she and her team has tested these
products and they do it each year using
state-of-the-art methods for safety
quality and value so you know that they
know what they're talking about so let's
get right to it Jessica how you doing
good how are you Nick good morning all
right good morning so you tested this
vacuum yes okay so our lab Pros love
everything on this table let's start
with the I home this is the Eclipse Pro
robot back okay and everyone loves a
robot vacuum because they are so
convenient right you can just set it
forget it come home to a clean house
it's the best this one moves row by Row
in your house and it creates a map of
your floor plan whether you're in a tiny
New York City apartment or a big house
which we love I like to set mine at
night you can use the app to program it
and then you can just wake up to a clean
house or while you're gone and it gets
under your furniture in your bed and
gets all those gross dust bunnies that I
get from my dog all the time so you just
set the app on your phone yep and you're
good to go okay so what's the price on
this this is 33 off it's 270 today
incredible deal on cbsdeals.com this
one's gonna go really fast that is a
great deal for a quality vacuum okay so
what about something that drivers might
want to keep in their car okay I'm glad
that you saw that because I really think
that everybody should have this in their
car it is a seven in one multi-tool by
react it does seven seven okay seven
things great price on this one today
this one is 44 off for 28 it is a
charger of course you can put it right
into the port okay and then you can take
it toss it in your bag you never have to
remember to charge it because it is
always plugged in but then also those
seven multi-functions flashlight seat
belt cutter in case of emergency glass
breaker so you can make sure that if
there's ever an emergency which of
course you hope there's not you can just
have this literally at your fingertips
oh there's a little blade under there
for a seat belt cutter yeah then I press
down here that's the pointy thing that
breaks the glass you've got an emergency
yep you hope you never need it you know
that you do again 44 off CBS deals
amazing amazing discount okay all right
so what do you have here when it comes
to something that might help remove the
toolbox that we're so used to having it
yes okay so you don't have to haul out
this clunky toolbox this is the Kelvin
23 it is 23 Tools in one I love this
product so much you can see it has a
pop-out screwdriver in it it also has a
tape measure it has a hammering surface
which is amazing and then this magnetic
tip is my favorite watch how this just
pops out I feel like oh so cool right
and then it has this magnetic tip so you
can keep all of your screws and your
nails here I actually got this from my
dad was an early Father's Day gift and I
just think it's the best person for
anyone who's super handy in your life
and then you don't have to worry about
all the Clutter look how happy he is
that guy that is great what's the price
on this this is 33 off 33.50 that's a
great amazing Father's Day gift amazing
gift for anyone handy yeah but Father's
Day is coming up though yeah it's true
you got to put on your list are you a
handy guy uh yes of course yes you will
be whether or not what do we have here
this is link my pet and I know you don't
have a dog but when you get one when you
get one when I get one
um this will be perfect so this is a GPS
tracker it is a smart wearable for your
pet it is a activity tracker and of
course you need that microchip to make
sure that your pet is safe but as a pet
owner myself the really sobering
statistic is 10 million animals go
missing every year this you get a live
look at where your pet is if they happen
to get out this is 40 off today this is
ninety dollars under a hundred dollars
oh you use it on big dogs too right the
dogs little dogs whatever you need to
keep your pet safe Jessica ties we
appreciate you of course we partner with
all of these companies to get these
deals to buy anything that you saw scan
the QR code on your screen or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping now